eric zemmour ou marine le pen fois la
bâche voilà c'est dur à avaler c'est une
vraie galère ses jokers
vous êtes obligé imaginons d'un deuxième
tour eric simon marina tu me fais pas
non parce qu'en plus c'est ça qui fait
le buzz et c'est ça ouais c'est vrai qu
on sait ça bien sûr il est en train de
provoquer un séisme dans le camp le pen
oui ça c'est vrai vous pensez vraiment
qu'ils font c'est qu'ils peuvent
terminer devant elle au premier tour je
pense que tout est possible et des gt
j'ai discuté avec des amis tout à
l'heure et ils sont persuadés que eric
zemmour va assécher marine le pen s'il
sait s'il se présente et qui va faire
plus qu'elle est que la halle à 18 dans
les derniers sondages il ya 11 et ils
sont persuadés parce qu'en fait ils
disent que marine le pen ce n'est plus
le vote de contestation aujourd'hui
c'est voilà eric zemmour c'est long
c'est lent c'est un long processus
on verra tout peut se passer mais elle
s'est banalisé elle est apparue comme
incompétente ou au moins au moment du
fameux débat entre les deux tours avec
magna mâcon les régionales ont été très
mauvaises et comme elle s'est banalisé
dans le camp on va dire identitaire dans
ce camp de la droite extrême eric
zemmour apparaît comme la nouveauté je
vais rajouter un élément bon c'est pas
forcément un compliment vous êtes c'est
comme une partie de cet électorat envie
d'être fiers d'une culture d'une
histoire même s'il a tort même si ce
qu'ils disent parfois est horrible sur
le château de gaulle sur les gamins
juifs qui aurait pas dû être enterré en
lice par l est c était sa dernière
sortie mais il apparaît qu'il rend fier
cet électorat oui ce que je veux dire à
travers cette émission et que l'histoire
cela que sur ses succès ce qui n'est
plus le cas de deux mariages il
ressemble d'ailleurs d'une certaine
manière il est presque plus les
héritiers du père guy lepel que que de
l'avis du coup
était possible les gens
ce qui ressort c'est qu'aujourd'hui
marine le pen est les limites elle est
trop policé c'est à dire qu'elle a
tellement vous ne devrait pas que ça
aurait joué en pot et dijon à l'extrême
droite en france et de ne plus mener
plus plus modérée on devrait les
guillemets là dessus alors voulu montrer
que le rassemblement national est un
parti comme les autres aujourd'hui
justement c'est un parti comme les
autres et c'est ça qui je pense que si
l'entrée se passer c'est que la droite
extrême où l'extrême droite simplement
comme on veut et le national populisme
c'est c'est cette droite-là qui au fond
porte vision qui n'est évidemment pas la
mienne qui divise beaucoup le pays de
berre jean luc mélenchon avec qui
beaucoup de choses nous oppose à des des
choses plutôt juste il ya soir dans des
petites vidéos qu'il a fait hier mais
est qui et qui chauffait déjà cette
émission et d'autre des bailleurs mais
mais c'est vrai que c'est la
confrontation d'une certaine vision là
delà de la france mais quelle plus à
droite aujourd'hui pour vous marine le
pen ou eric zemmour a je pense que sur
le plan idéologique ce plan des idées ce
plan la culture politique c'est
incontestablement et reset est ouvert à
côté parce qu'il est dans un courant je
veux faire ça vend un peu mais d un
vieux courant qui hélas de charles
maurras c'était de droite d'extrême
droite français de l'entre-deux-guerres
des références à pétain enfin le départ
républicains au sens historique du terme
donc je pense beaucoup plus à droite il
vous fait peur il faut gagner vous savez
dans dans le monde politique
d'aujourd'hui tout est possible
j'imagine qu'au etats unis beaucoup de
gens ont dit rob ne peut pas gagner
alors c'est sûr modèle donne cet exemple
un cahier suspect - est-ce que cela
s'est passé alors y ait une différence
et get de tours vrai que est évidemment
le deuxième taux est un moyen de ceux de
se rattraper mais il peut surtout faire
abaisser le seuil de qualification au
deuxième tour si le pen s'écroule que
lui monté que la droite républicaine par
exemple un candidat qui a qui arrivent à
faire un score qui aura 14 15 mai voire
plus multiples ou peut être qualifier au
deuxième tour avec 16 ou 17 % c'est ce
qu'a estimé jean marc jean marie le pen
avait les jambes voilà avec 16% à peine
un peu plus que 5 mois en 2002 donc ça
peut ça peut tout changer et emmanuel
macron peut se retrouver sur s'ils
résistent je crois que ça devrait être
le cas face à xavier bertrand ou à
valérie pécresse voit eric zemmour tout
est possible et attention avec un pays
qui a une abstention massive aux
régionales oui on a dit c'est pas grave
si c'est très grave docteur et
deuxièmement avec les gilet jaune et
avec une contestation civique il ya
quand même beau les gens sont très
fâchés sur le très en colère si on va
tuer attention sauf que pardon mais je
m'essaie à l'abattée l'autre jour a
déclaré c'est lequel il a dit on d'un
peu à tous les intellectuels et les
hommes politiques qui ont été débattre
face à zemmour qui l'ont fait exister
qui l'ont fait naître à la télévision en
allant dé battre un peu comme ça face à
un professeur et vous avez fait partie
de ces gens j'ai vu d'ailleurs le débat
qui a débattu a salué ce que vous le
regrettez non pas du tout alors là je
pense que alors ce débat zemmour est
fabriqué par la presse d'accord il a
passé des années il est journaliste
d'ailleurs au figaro ensuite il a passé
des années à chez ruquier on n'est pas
couché ensuite sur rtl les grandes
radios populaires bon donc non et puisse
le succès de céline mais ça c'était
prévu on avait parlé tous les deux mais
le l'avait adoubé en débattre mais
d'autres n'est alors l'idée au débat
alors aujourd'hui de ne pas débattre
dans la société d'aujourd'hui d'autant
plus qu'avec lui ça a été une heure où
il a parlé beaucoup d'histoires beaucoup
du passé peut-être trop mais moi je suis
allé avec avec mon expérience
les études d'histoire que j'ai fait mon
goût pour le passé mais aussi j'espère
pour futur de la france lui dire que
cette vision de l'histoire ne
correspondait pas à la mienne et à celle
qu'il fallait pour ce pays et pourrait
pourrir de de lui-même d'eau il faut y
aller pour combative que sinon il est
seul à défendre saisir et donc mélenchon
a raison de débattre cette plus avec lui
tout ce que vous n'êtes plus mélenchon
anne hidalgo
avec mélenchon il ya quand même des
fossés et le prix de vente m'a traité de
nazi une fois savons pas quand même
ouais c'est très bien connu mélenchon au
plc penh il est lé talent
évidemment je l'écouté puis représente
un courant politique dans ce pays il a
fait 17 ou 18 % aux dernières
présidentielles mais il ya trop de
choses qui nous sépare notamment sur la
vision de la de la france allait déposer
c'est vrai qu'un fossé aussi entrain
hidalgo et vous également mais il est
frais